For this programming exercise, you need to alter the variable tenure,
so that way, it was measured in years instead of days. And
this should make a lot of sense, since 365 days would
be one year, and 730 days would be two years. Now for
the binwidth, let's set it equal to one so we get
a count for yearly users. Running this code, we can see our
histogram. And notice here that we have a different color. And I
did that by changing the hex code. To get a finer view
of our data, we could set the bandwidth equal to .25. It
looks like the bulk of our users had had less than two and
a half years on Facebook. To improve this plot in one more
way, I can change the x axis, so that way it increments by
one year. To do that, I can add the layer of scale
x continuous, and set the breaks from one to seven. I'm also going to
limit our data so that we only see users from zero to seven
years. Writing this code, we can see we have a very nice histogram.